review here I'm here in Davos 2012 I'm a
professor of behavioral and brain
sciences at xmas a university and we're
here to talk about the favorite Davos
moment for me it's the social
interaction this incredible dynamics
when you meet people in the congress
center and you just see the name tags
and realize the person is nobel prize
and you shot an incredible minutes
talking about state of world what should
we do and of course being lucky enough
to be a young global leader interactions
with my fellow young global leaders were
just incredible with getting ideas from
people who do so many different great
things in philanthropy etc and our
bonuses of course and the big bonus for
I think for many of us young global
leaders was to have this young global
leader party and at some points Mick
Jagger trashed in the body and we danced
with net Jagger so this had to be the
Davos moment as far as we're concerned